the United States and Iran don't agree
on much but there's one thing both
countries see eye-to-eye on Isis has got
to go while both the u.s. and Iran are
working with the Iraqi government in the
fight against Isis only one of those
countries has boots on the ground
Iran's oakwoods force a secretive elite
special ops team is leading the battle
but who exactly is the Alcott's military
force eclipse is a special ops unit of
the Iranian Revolutionary Guard that was
formed after the 1979 Iranian Revolution
much of their activities are carried out
in the shadows and you might call them
Iran's answer to the US Navy SEALs the
commander Qasem Soleimani has been
designated a terrorist by the u.s. more
than once and he spent most of his
career directing covert operations in
secret until now since taking charge of
the fight against isis Soleimani has
become somewhat of a celebrity in Iran
he's been the focus of news reports
documentaries even music videos and
suleiman and his men only report to one
man Iran's supreme leader Ayatollah Ali
Khamenei Qasem Soleimani enough quotes
our key allies of Iraq in fighting Isis
and that's because of course his core
mission is to train and support allied
militia groups outside of Iran with
weapons cache and intelligence the
Alcott's force has a murky history of
doing just that for over three decades
they began conducting secret missions in
Iraq Kurdish region during the iran-iraq
war in the 1980s the force has also
allegedly supported Hezbollah in Lebanon
the Houthis in Yemen and helped to crush
the uprisings in Syria not long ago the
u.s. accused outputs of arming Shia
militia groups to attack US troops
during the Iraq war I can say with
certainty that the cuts force a part of
the Iranian government has provided
these sophisticated IEDs that have
harmed our troops but despite a rocky
history with the United States both Iran
and the u.s. share the same goal of
defeating Isis as arjan tabata by told
us there's
elements of each other's presence in
Iraq there is evidence that both sides
know what the other side is doing every
time there have been reports of Iran
doing something or the u.s. doing
something somebody and the other
administration has come out and said
well yes we are aware of this so there
seems to be some level of tactical
cooperation as opposed to strategic
cooperation so why are Iran's elite
forces on the front lines of the battle
against Isis well to Iran Isis is a very
real and direct threat
it makes the Ron Ian's a bit worried so
I think that that is also part of the
reason why the Kochs forces are so
present and the general Soleimani is
running around Iraq taking selfies as
partly to appease the domestic audience
back home so what does Iran's presence
in Iraq mean as the United States
retrains the Iraqi army to combat Isis
the Iraqi government is looking for any
additional help it can get and that
means Iraq is becoming more dependent on
Iran and Iranian trained militias which
only strengthens Iran's influence in the
region
you